dahlia está subiendo a un taxi en la ciudad
desde mexico en la tarifa de taxi incluye un
cargo 2 pase de 50 pesos que aplica
al acercarse y un costo adicional de 2 50
Pesos de 50 puntos por kilómetro
apelar si alia simplemente no tenía uno
peso buen boleto apela cinco
kilómetros
le da un soborno a un taxista
cuánto dinero título al final y
irrevocable
bn primero calcula la tarifa del taxi
de fifa en taxi bns lleno 50 para quedarse
con la base del 50 de posición base pero
cinco kilómetros
*de los 50 que si me gustan cada uno
kilómetro
Estoy siendo igual al 50 de la tarifa
base pero cinco por 2 50 y se puso 50 y
esto nos da un resultado de 15 pesos y
ahora cobramos el arancel pero hay soborno
la tarifa pero pronto pe
entonces nos sacamos 15 pesos de ahi
tarifa pero creo que tomó el taxista
esto es igual a 16 pesos ganar no
terminamos porque la fila comenzaba con
bien de pesos y queremos saber cuanto
lennon así es el intercambio que recibí
del taxista será tu biblioteca de 20 pesos
delivery - desde 16 pesos me gusto la tarifa
pero del soborno y bien tener menos de seis es
igual a 44 pesos y este es el resultado de
nuestro problema